[Music]
this Memorial Day we take the time to
honor those who gave the ultimate
sacrifice and to express our gratitude
and tonight we'd like to introduce you
to Sarah Verado she's the executive
director for the national nonprofit
assisting severely wounded veterans and
their caregivers and she's also a
caregiver to her husband Michael one of
the most severely wounded veterans
injured in Afghanistan
he's now undergoing his 119th surgery
Sarah welcome to the angle first of all
I had a chance to talk to you on radio
it's so inspiring
your husband has suffered greatly he has
been through more surgeries and anyone
can bear and remember but you've kind of
you've turned your focus not just to
complete a care of him but also to help
raise money for these trach chairs and
other items and devices that our
veterans need that VA benefits don't
necessarily cover I realized that really
when when Michael left the army his war
ended in mine began and mine was fought
on the homefront against the very
institution that I thought was going to
take care of him the VA it was a very
bureaucratic and long process and that's
what I love about the independence fund
is that we we say if this is an unmet
need we're going to fill it with the
trach wheelchairs and anything else that
a bit of sports equipment that these
heroes need so independence fund dot org
yes ma'am and you guys have already
raised sixty million bucks Bill O'Reilly
has helped raise millions and millions
of dollars we want to raise all many
million more for you your husband lost
his leg and most of one-armed correct
and how is that you have three young
daughters how is life today well we feel
very blessed as we go into Memorial Day
weekend many of my dearest friends are
widows and so they have folded American
flags in place of their husbands and so
our life is certainly so much more
challenging than I would have ever
predicted when I started this journey
with Michael but our blessing so far
outweigh our burdens we're very very
lucky but the wounded the fight never
ends and we know that here at the
independence fund and we're with them
and their families every step of the way
the VA mission Act I bet you'll be on
board just when the president signs that
early June
it's gonna do a lot to help our veterans
for this president gets very little
credit from the media but this is a
bipartisan effort a lot more money will
go to rehabilitation helping those in
need you know my husband we've had a
chance to spend a lot of time with the
president with his family he has an
unmatched heart for America's veterans
and he campaigned unequivocally on a
promise that veterans will be able to
choose his or her own health care
provider and its promise made promise
kept were thrilled by VA mission Act and
the news when you got it April 24th 2010
take us back to that date Michael and I
weren't married at the time we so I got
it actually from his mother but you know
we were together in high school
sorry not dating but we we went to high
school together during the events of
September 11th and it spurred his call
to action and so was not surprised to
learn that when Michael does something
he goes all in all the way and so he was
so proud he'd go back tomorrow if they'd
let him 82nd airborne best of the best
you know going back to Kandahar like so
many of our bravest stepped on an IEE d
there planted horrific vicious things
and I'm gonna see you at Walter Reed I
hope next week and get a chance to spend
some time with him independence fund org
please give what you can an amazing
organization it's the least we could do
frankly I hope you have a meaningful
Memorial Day weekend and we'll be in
touch and I'll see you next week that
says one all right thanks so much very
inspiring